all right
movie retrospective time here's another
one that's been on the list for a really
long time i can't remember even uh who
requested it because it was such a long
time ago
this is the 1980 movie the ninth
configuration
this is probably one of the weirdest
movies that we've done on this show and
that's saying something
i couldn't really get into it it's about
an insane asylum a military insane
asylum in this old [ __ ] spooky castle
in the middle
there's a lot of [ __ ] about the movie
that doesn't really to me didn't really
jive
it's got all spooky statues in it a
bunch of crazy dudes
i was about i've seen it a couple times
this thing this is the second time i've
seen it i was probably about 20 minutes
into it i'm like man
i gotta check out it so jenny's gonna do
most of the review
this is a very yeah this is a really
weird i'm not even really sure
what genre i would place this in
it's kind of like it almost it starts
out as almost kind of like
a farce like a comic i was going to say
absurdist
yeah it is very absurdist but then as it
goes on it kind of gets more
philosophical and then almost becomes a
horror movie sort of um so it's like a
very strange
uh film it's kind of like i don't even
know if they they don't really make [ __ ]
like this anymore
all-star cast too it's got everything
everybody's everybody
everybody's doing it yeah oh my god
there's like so many like awesome
people stacy keach is in this tom atkins
has a very small role
um [ __ ] uh what's that dude uh
stacy keach is in it ed flanders is in
it um
just [ __ ] everybody everybody's been
around scott wilson is in this if you've
been around
as long as we have you just recognize
everybody in it you're like oh that's a
dude from there
yeah jason miller uh you know from the
exorcist is in it uh which is
yeah so the the history of how this one
came about is actually
uh quite fascinating so this was
actually written and directed
by uh william peter blatty who obviously
uh
wrote the book the exorcist which was
directed by william friedkin
now this story was initially he
initially wrote it as a novel
in 1966 called twinkle twinkle killer
kane
now in its initial iteration i haven't
read either because he rewrote it later
but i haven't read either version of the
novel
apparently according to him the 1966
version which he said he liked a little
bit better was actually more of a
straight up
like a comic sort of farce
um that did have some stuff to say you
know about various
philosophical issues about life about
you know good and evil
religion you know things like that
whether god exists and stuff
um so he ends up so he goes off he
writes that
and then he goes off and does the
exorcist with william friedkin and
everything
and then he decides that he kind of
wants to
rework this story um and so he rewrites
the novel
with essentially the same story but i
guess with a little bit more of a
serious tone and like written a little
bit better
so the novel which he renamed the ninth
configuration came out in 1978.
now he wrote a screenplay to go along
with it he wanted william friedkin to
direct it who had directed the exorcist
but in the end um he decided that he was
going to
uh do it himself now
i don't know if it was just because of
how
strange this movie is um
but it kind of got passed around from uh
you know from uh studio to studio
um you know friedkin or william peter
blatty didn't really want to work with
uh
i believe it was warner brothers who had
done exorcists because they had like
[ __ ] him out of some of the money and
so he was like still mad about it so he
took it somewhere else it was paramount
and then they kind of sat on it for a
while and then you know it just kind of
got passed around it didn't get made so
what he ended up doing finally
was he ended up putting up two million
dollars of his own money
like he sold a house that he had that
was must be nice
let's just i'll just sell this house and
get two million dollars to make it maybe
i had several
yeah he did um so yeah so he got two
million dollars and then he got
pepsico to put up the other two million
dollars
which is why there is a prominent uh
pepsi
vending machine in a scene in this movie
and also
one of the characters mentions fritos at
one point because i believe fritos are
also owned by
pepsico so
so this story it's so yeah it's like the
dirty dozen
2001 a space odyssey [ __ ] some kind
of vampire movie like
dracula it's kind of like uh
kind of like the exorcist and it's kind
of like uh
it's kind of like what was the one with
the um the damn all the hulu
religious hallucinations and [ __ ]
[ __ ] what altered
altered states this reminds me the tone
of this reminds me a little bit of
alternative
except funnier yeah if altered states
was
a comedy and mixed with mash yeah
the series mash not so much dirty kind
of remind
this is probably the closest thing in
tone because mash was like had a very
serious
you know military kind of thing going on
but then there was like absurdus as well
so maybe that so maybe it's not as weird
as i'm thinking it was
yeah it had a big sci-fi kind of horror
element into in it
but i'm not i'm not sure i understood it
i really kind of stopped paying
attention to it i didn't really walk out
on the movie
i just started to be like man i can't
fight with this movie anymore it's just
i can't fight with it it was doing stuff
to me
it was doing stuff to you yeah yeah
well as i said this is going to be one
of those movies
okay one of the things that i started to
shut down is that there was a lot of
military stuff me being a military man
was a lot of military inaccuracies in it
and and and a lot of fake military
culture
as soon as they start faking the
military culture i check out i'm like uh
this wasn't written by somebody that
knows what they're talking about but a
person who is
not military wouldn't have a problem
with this movie yeah
probably not and like i said it's kind
of set in
it's i'm not going to say that it's set
in a dream world
but it's set in a in a way that's kind
of
outside of main stream society so much
that it can almost seem like an
alternate
universe you know what i mean because it
says weird
because i mean pretty much the whole
thing takes place in it i think it was
supposed to be serious
but it was also supposed to make you uh
uh kind of [ __ ] dis disoriented
it is very disorienting to make you
question your own sanity
yeah big time it was supposed to do big
time but because they started
playing a bunch of games about who's
crazy yeah and uh
i know i'm not crazy you can't [ __ ] with
me like that
you can't [ __ ] with me like that movie
yeah exactly stop it
i don't know i'm always really i'm all i
got to tell you though i'm always really
um really i don't really believe people
when they say they're not crazy
i think everybody's a little bit crazy
not crazy i mean you know what i mean
if you if i i feel like it's really the
only crazy craziest people that think
they're not crazy
okay everyone's alone keep telling
yourself that this movie actually did
end up it got like a whole bunch of
golden globe nominations
um you know it didn't win like best
picture but it did get um
best screenplay and i will say that the
first half of this movie
there is some really really funny [ __ ]
in this
one of my favorite things about it is
that jason miller's character he was the
guy that played
damian karis in the exorcist obviously
he is
his uh craziness is that he is putting
on
a production of julius caesar uh you
know the william shakespeare play
uh but entirely with dogs so
so him and the dude from uh joe spinell
from [ __ ] maniac who's
playing his casting director uh you know
that's a fun fact there
the the whole thing of them like the
scenes of them trying to decide what
breeds of dogs are like
good for each part like in julius caesar
and hamlet and stuff like that just
cracked me the [ __ ] up
i don't know that for some reason that
was like very funny to me
but it's the whole first half is kind of
like that it's like it's
very farcical because so the setup of it
is is that it's after some it's
some undisclosed time in the mid to late
1970s they don't really tell you what
year it is
you're presuming that a lot of these are
vietnam war veterans that have come back
and are not right now
it's the the premise of the movie is
that
you know the military the government or
whatever has
established these kind of secret insane
asylums
because i kind of feel like they suspect
that these people
the soldiers that are coming back that
are all like mentally messed up that
they're
faking or something so they're trying to
determine whether these people are
faking or not
so they have like these kind of
secretive insane asylums essentially
so the funny thing about this is that in
the context of the movie
it's this huge like castle pretty much
like in these mountains and it's
supposed to be in the pacific northwest
they don't tell you where they just say
pacific northwest
generally and there's one throwaway line
in the movie
um where ed flanders says the other guy
yeah this castle was like some
counter duchess or something and she had
the castle brought here like brick by
brick and built here
because as we were saying we're like i
don't know if there's any castles that
look like that in the pacific yeah this
thing's huge it's 20 stories tall
the reason is it's gigantic it's jai
[ __ ] enormous you wouldn't you
couldn't move it yeah
that's what i mean even brick by brick
that would just take it's at least 20
i was trying to measure it was at least
20 stories tall i mean it's about yeah
and you know it was the size of a
[ __ ] mountain
well i think it might be a miniature no
it's not it's real
it's uh yeah but it's not the pacific
northwest it's in
hungary okay yeah because one of the
stipulations of pepsico
giving william peter blatty two million
dollars to make this movie was that they
film it in hungary because i guess they
had some kind of like
deal with deal like that with some
filmmaking [ __ ] there
like some kind of block with their
plants or whatever whose castle was that
i don't know
i don't know whose it was um it's cold
but yeah it's massive it's probably
about 20 stories tall
quarter of a mile [ __ ] across the
bottom it's big
yeah it's this it's it's a whole city
it's
pretty much yeah you know but yeah that
is a real castle
yeah so yeah they shot it in hungary
yeah it's like [ __ ] maybe 15 stories
or just walls
and then on the top it's got all these
domes and spires and
it's cool as [ __ ] there's windows in it
[Laughter]
gigantic man heating and cooling that
thing would be a big i'm sure it's not
sure it's not tim you have to put a
window unit
and then just stay in that room
yeah so so there's this asylum
and essentially there's all these uh you
know soldiers there that are suffering
from various
mental illnesses and delusions and uh
it's super crazy and it does seem like i
mean when
the movie begins um you see that it's
just kind of this crate like nobody has
any discipline
or anything like that everyone's just
running around acting like nut cases
like they
are and so at the beginning of the movie
they get
and i'm going to spoil this okay so if
you've never seen it
then then don't watch this if you want
to watch it
like i said this is this is going to be
a very off-putting or a very
polarizing movie either you're going to
be super into it
or you're it or you're just going to be
like no i don't like it or i don't get
it or anything like that it's just a
very very polarizing movie
it's funny because i was watching a
thing earlier that's very famous uh
british film critic mark carmod and this
is actually one of his very favorite
movies ever a lot of british people seem
to be into it i don't know why like a
lot of british
critics that i saw like really liked it
so
so at the beginning of the movie they
have uh stacy keach
arrives playing uh ostensibly
a psychiatrist who is coming there he's
a colonel
and he's coming there in order to kind
of um you know help these
dudes out now when he gets there
he meets this other uh doctor this
doctor guy who's played
by ed flanders his name is colonel fell
and he kind of like
shows him the ropes and like introduces
him to all these like crazy characters
one of whom has a jet pack which
they should have done more with that it
was just like one there's like one throw
away so like a jet pack a guy in a
superman outfit it's like they just do
like all these little throwaway gags
well he's got bikers in it too bikers
astronauts [ __ ] soldiers [ __ ]
crazy man [ __ ]
every it's just it's just nuts it's all
over the place it's just it's it's a
crazy crazy movie but
there is the thing about it though is
that as weird as it is like as it goes
on
because at the beginning it just seems
super like shambolic and you have like
no
idea what's going on because in the
beginning it just seems like a farcical
like comedy
which it kind of is but with kind of a
dark edge to it but as it goes on it's
like makes more more sense
um so oh and fun fact the astronaut
that's in this because one of the guys
who's kind of like the main
crazy person i guess you could say in
the asylum uh
is a guy named billy cutshaw and he was
an astronaut
who was supposed to go like on a moon
mission but
before the he was going into the you
know into the launch pad or whatever
he had like a mental breakdown and like
flipped out and like did all kind of
crazy [ __ ] and they kind of dragged him
away and put him in this thing
so um he's played by scott wilson which
uh people nowadays will
know as uh herschel from the walking
dead he was also in uh
[ __ ] he was in cold blood he was in like
a whole bunch of [ __ ] back in the day
and um so he's kind of like the main
person that interacts with uh stacy
keich's character
colonel kane and the two of them kind of
get into
a lot of philosophical discussions about
how colonel kane
thinks that you know god exists because
there's good in the world
whereas um you know cutshaw
is kind of an atheist and is very
cynical and just thinks everyone is
terrible and that the whole world is
evil and there's no saving it and
there's no redemption or anything so
that's kind of like the central theme of
this movie is the theme of
you know even though there is so much
evil in the world is about like you know
the existence of god and stuff like
because this is william peter blatty who
wrote the exorcist see
a lot of the themes carry over and
another like
i was gonna say before another fun fact
the astronaut in this cut shaw
um william peter blatty has said that
when he rewrote
the novel the ninth configuration he
made it so that that astronaut
was the same one that was at the party
in the exorcist where reagan comes down
and says you're gonna die up there
that's supposed to be the same astronaut
yeah so
he's like making it like a whole
in-universe type of thing
but yeah so they start having all these
discussions about that and meanwhile
you can see there's all this kind of
crazy [ __ ] going on in the asylum
but then you can kind of see that
colonel kane who is ostensibly the
psychiatrist and is supposed to have his
[ __ ] together
then maybe he might not be entirely
there either
because he has these weird he started
having these weird nightmares
um he talks to colonel fell that it's
like oh i keep having the same nightmare
but it's not my nightmare like it
belonged to my
brother who was a very famous i guess he
was like a famous like marine in vietnam
or something like that called killer
kane
who had like killed a bunch of people
including like a little boy and he'd
like cut his head off like he had done
all these like atrocities
so so he's saying that he that that guy
is dead
his brother's dead but that he's having
his nightmares because his brother told
him about them and it's like upsetting
him a lot
and some of the inmates at the asylum
start to speculate that maybe colonel
kane is
as crazy or crazier than they are
so as i said all of this kind of stuff
goes on him and cutshaw are having all
these
you know discussions about um you know
the meaning of life and
you know good and evil and all this
other stuff they have this one
discussion
which actually be ends up being really
important later on
over um you know
colonel kane saying that you know
there's good in the world why don't you
think that god exists because there's
good in the world because
cutshaw is saying that's like well i
don't think that there's a god because
look at all the evil in the world
and so they're kind of like coming to
head about that and he said well look at
all the self-sacrifice look at a soldier
that throws himself on a grenade and
like saves all his people and you know
the other guy saying that's
[ __ ] that's just like a reflex
action and that's he so he's like trying
to shoot down everything
and so cut shaw says to him he's like
think of one single
um you know episode from your own life
where someone sacrificed their life for
someone else from your own life i want
something from your own personal
experience
and kane can't think of anything and
like i said that's a very
significant uh kind of scene because it
like plays out later on
so as it goes on you find out
that colonel kane because this other uh
this other um
inmate shows up and this other inmate
that shows up at the asylum
turns out that he knew
killer kane who is supposedly uh
you know this guy's brother but in
actuality i'm sure no one will be
surprised to know that it wasn't his
brother it was actually him
so he was the guy that he had like
killed all these innocent people like
women and children they're implying
um they do show a scene of him like with
a kid's head like holding a kid's head
or whatever that he's cut off
and what he did was so atrocious
that he essentially split off into two
personalities
so like he basically took the evil part
of him
and killed it and now he
became his actual brother who it turned
out as colonel fell the doctor
who they were kind of pretending they
didn't know each other but colonel fell
has actually been in charge of him the
whole time
like looking after him um because so
he so he is trying to redeem himself by
saying that that guy is not there
anymore that guy's dead now and now i'm
trying to help people
you know what i mean because he so he's
trying to help all these um
you know other inmates in this mental
asylum and the one thing that he's doing
and he got this idea from jason miller's
character talking about the dogs and
about hamlet and everything
and he had a theory about hamlet that
hamlet was essentially
neither really insane or pretending to
be insane
he's just basically like he's pretending
to be insane to keep from really going
insane
and that gives kane the idea that maybe
all of these
um maybe that will help the men in the
asylum if we just
indulge their you know delusions
so basically he does that like he gets
all this money like there's one group of
them it's like we want to reenact the
great escape so he gets all the stuff he
gets nazi uniforms he gets like all this
and everyone has to pretend ever has to
like play along
and like the one guy that's like you
know the artist and like they give him
like
[ __ ] like for michelangelo so you can
paint on the ceiling and it's like they
just
you know they just indulge all their
delusions in the hopes that it will
make them get better uh which is
essentially what they're doing with kane
because they're letting him
think that he's a psychiatrist and that
he's helping these people
because they think that that will make
him get better
like after he like dissociated because
of like all the people that he killed
and he had like a [ __ ] freak out and
a trauma about it
so as it goes on um once uh
cut shaw who has actually him and uh
kane have developed a friendship but
once kun
cutshaw finds out that kane is actually
killer kane who like i said is very well
known for his atrocities
um he flips out he escapes from the
asylum he ends up at this bar
and then all these bikers there
recognize him because apparently it was
kind of a big news story like this
astronaut that flipped out like before
going to the moon or whatever
and so they start like taunting him and
like pouring beer on him like beating
the [ __ ] out of him
so kane actually comes to comes to his
rescue
and the bikers start because there's a
whole bunch of bikers and there's only
two of them does the bikers start like
[ __ ] with them
and essentially kane lets
these bikers like humiliate him because
he thinks that
then the bikers will let them leave um
but then finally it gets to a point
where the bikers are actually going to
rape
cutshaw and that makes kane snap back
into killer cane mode and he essentially
kills all the bikers pretty much with
his bare hands
so they take him back to the uh asylum
and um you know paranormal to me
it yeah it well i think they were kind
of i don't even know
those people were there yeah there was
some paranormal [ __ ]
um going on in this like i said with the
existence of god because there's another
conversation that cutshaw and cain have
um
because like i said about the whole you
know does god exist issue
where cutshaw says to kane he's like you
know if you die before me
give you know give me a sign that
there's an afterlife because i want
proof
you know what i mean so there so there
is so that actually does happen at the
end
where he gives him a sign that he
actually is like contacting him
so there is a little bit of a paranormal
element to this so
i think the thing about it they're
trying to essentially make cain
like a christ figure a little bit not
exactly but in the way that you know he
goes
and eventually kills all these people to
save cutshaw
and then when he comes back to the
castle and the cops want to take him
because they're like look we know he was
provoked but he just straight up
murdered like a whole bar full of people
um you know so we have to take him into
custody
but he talks to cutshaw and basically
they have a conversation because one of
kane's things that he always keeps
asking cutshaw is like why did you
you know flip out why did you go mental
or pretend to go mental or whatever it
was before you went to the moon like
what
was the problem and he would never tell
him like throughout the whole movie and
then finally at the end of the movie he
says
i you know that he was afraid that he
was afraid he would go out in space he
would and he would die
all alone and there was just nothing out
there like no god no nothing
and so that terrified him more than
anything so he essentially
just had like a flip out and he didn't
want to go so after he admits that
then kane as it turns out um
he ends up killing himself and he's
doing it
because he's like uh one i want this to
shock you
back into sanity essentially he called
it shock treatment
and he's like and two this is an example
from my personal life of somebody
sacrificing themselves for another
meaning that god exists right so that
was kind of the conversation that they
had so he actually essentially kills
himself
to make cutshaw better is what he's
doing yeah
i guess that's what you got out of it to
me it was just kind of it seemed like a
jumble
of a lot no because you really had to
pay attention to what everybody was
saying
and like what like all the conversations
they were having it does seem like that
at first like i said it seems very
shambolic
but as it goes on you kind of
you you figure out like what everything
means that there's a bunch of there was
a bunch of subliminal imagery too
inside the castle where they're doing
all this therapy there's these all these
creepy [ __ ] statues of
like mourning figures and robes and damn
demons and stuff so i think there was
i think there was some subliminal and
not some little bit symbolic stuff going
on in there too but i
i don't like i said i i i i this movie
didn't get me early on so i just
yeah well i mean i could tell there was
kind of a deeper undertone or at least
it was yeah
there was a deeper undertone it just it
wasn't for me i mean yeah
pretty much the whole the whole point of
the story was redemption i mean they
were saying that someone like kane
who had done like these horribly evil
things
that he could still be redeemed he still
helped people
um and you know in bladdy's mind because
like i said blatty was a catholic he
wrote you know the exorcist was a very
kind of catholic movie
and he so a lot of his um stories like
go into that
like that question of faith and
redemption and everything like that
so that was kind of what he was getting
at that kane was like an evil person
but he redeemed himself at the end so
even
so it's almost kind of like it's sad but
it's also kind of like a hopeful movie
because it's like someone as evil as
that could still redeem himself and he
still sacrificed himself for someone
else
um and you see at the end that indeed
cutshaw has you know has gotten better
and has like you know regained his
sanity and he's back in uniform he's
essentially back the card that he comes
in still has like nasa plates so he's
essentially like gone back to
being an astronaut or whatever it was
and maybe he's gotten over his phobia
and he goes into the castle which is now
abandoned
which implies i guess that all the
inmates that were in there got better um
you know
so so that was kind of like a hopeful
message as well
and then at the very end when he gets
back in the car like after he's gone
into the thing and looked around and
like read the letter from
kane and everything and he gets back in
there and finds uh
a saint christopher medal which hadn't
been there before like it was left in
the car so like i said that was like a
supernatural or like a paranormal thing
and he turns it over and there's
something on the back
and he sees that it's the same saint
christopher medal that he gave to kane
early on in the movie
which proves to him that was the sign
that cain was
contacting him essentially from the
afterlife and telling him
it's okay you're not gonna die alone
there is an afterlife and
you know i'll be wait or because he says
in the letter i'll see you again
so that's what he says so that's so even
though
like i said this is a weird weird movie
and it's not going to be like
everybody's cup of tea because the tone
of it
is very strange um even for 1980 because
i know some weird movies came out in the
70s like in early 80s
but this is a very strange like you said
it's almost kind of like
mash but it's a lot weirder than that
yeah and there's like a lot of weird
dream imagery like with the astronaut on
the moon and then there's like
jesus on the cross like on the moon and
[ __ ] like that the movie starts with a
song that has
lyrics yeah you only saw that [ __ ] like
in the 70s and it's like country lyrics
or
or not really like but it's a folk song
like a folk song and then it cuts out
and then it
it's just weird the whole movies it is
very strangely edited
yeah but maybe i think that's more um it
was a product
that's a product of the time that's not
so much you know because this this is
somebody who made movies before and
uh but yeah so this like i said this is
free on tubey
at the moment uh if you want to watch it
that's where i watched it
it's it might be free on youtube too but
whatever um
so if you are into the exorcist or
you've liked like any of his other books
and you're kind of interested in that
theme this is kind of like the exorcist
meets mash meets altered states
meets 30 dozen meets 30 dozen meets
a biker movie yeah that biker better
then it's kind of weird
like the bikers are very strange like
they he has like the
the biker the biker at the end reminded
me of like
uh what phantom of the paradise or i
think it reminded me of phantom of the
paradise
wes from mad max that too yeah it was
kind of like that because
yeah i can't i can't think of all those
[ __ ] biker gangs i think it was only
in movies biker gangs wearing all that
like cat eye
eyeliner if you were a real biker you
got your ass kicked
or wearing an eyeliner i wanted to say
too i forgot to mention
other than like i i said like my
favorite crazy person in this was jason
miller like i said damian carris who was
doing the thing with the dogs just
because
i just he put so much thought into what
breed of dog was gonna play
each part in the play and it just i
don't know it made me laugh because it
was almost like kind of perfect in the
explanations yeah but there was another
guy
in it and he only had like two scenes he
was the guy
like near the beginning he was like
knocking holes in the walls of the
castle
and he said it was because that he
believed that he could walk through the
walls
well that anybody could walk through the
walls but he had tried to do it and had
failed
so he was punishing the atoms of the
walls by hitting them with the hammer
so that next time the atoms would know
to like move
out of the way to let him through the
wall and then so just that whole
converse and he was like super creepy
and serious like the way he was talking
about it
and then like later on they had a scene
where he was in the water and he was
talking about how much better like the
atoms of the water were because they
just let you move around in there freely
instead of like
those [ __ ] atoms in the wall that had
to be beat up
and like i said there's a scene there's
just this throwaway scene it's like a
second
where like somebody just flies by in a
jet pack it's like the dude comes out
with the superman cause he wants to be
in the shakespeare play too and he wants
to play superman
and like come in and like rescue
somebody and like [ __ ]
it's just like crazy [ __ ] like that so
the first half of it
is like just this really weird
like comedy sort of and then it just
goes into this like weird it's just a
very very very strange movie
so if you're into like really really
weird movies from this time period
this might be up your alley but like i
said don't hit me if you don't like it
because yeah i thought it was tiresome
it's a very very polarizing yeah movie
and it takes a while to
get into its groove and you really have
to like listen all their conversations i
thought it was tiresome i thought the
humor was kind of stale
so that's just it depended on the person
like some of the [ __ ] was really funny
like some of the [ __ ] that scott
wilson's character said like the
astronaut was really funny she depends
on your taste
but yeah it wasn't to my taste it was
yeah it but it's just a really weird
movie but like i said if you want to
watch it it's on tubey
uh just check it out and tell me what
you think about it i'm really curious
and i was like i said i
forgive me i can't remember who
recommended that we do this but it's
been on my list for a really long time
so i'm finally getting around to it uh
so that'll do it and uh remember like
share subscribe
subscribe and uh we'll see you next time
you